This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon footprint.
And you can also sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon footprint
or support rainforest protection projects.
When you are in the world of microbes, it does not
seem necessary to think of the largest land mammal
on earth. What could elephants possibly have to
do with a ciliate? When you say this out loud,
any potential connection seems dubious at best.
However, if you look at the Dileptus,
you see an elongated, moving body, one that
seems like it’s made up entirely of snout—like
an elephant’s trunk, disembodied and shrunk
down so that it can survive all on its own.
But unlike the elephant, Dileptus is no gentle
giant. It isn’t moving around because it wants
to play or drink water. No,the dileptus is
waving around because it is loaded with toxins
and it wants to put them to good use.
Now, this may be surprising given its
general blob-like appearance, but the dileptus’
body is divided into two distinct regions:
the proboscis and the trunk, which is confusing
because the trunk on the dileptus is not actually
the elephant trunk-like part of the organism.
The trunk is, in this case, more like the trunk
of a tree, it’s the base for the rest of the
dileptus’ body. The proboscis is the snout, the
part that extends to the rest of the microcosmos
and examines it, looking for something to eat.
And interestingly where the proboscis and
the trunk connect lies the dileptus’ mouth,
a cavity lined with hair-like cilia that continues
down the length of the proboscis. The dileptus can
use these cilia to generate currents in the
water that carry food to its oral cavity. You
can imagine it a bit like if your arm hairs could
stir up the air around you and levitate the snack
in your hand all the way to your mouth. Which,
now that I’m thinking about it, sounds amazing.
But before the cilia can work their
magic, the dileptus has to catch its food.
And that’s unfortunate for the Spirostomum at
the bottom left corner. It does not know that
on the other side of that piece of debris is
a predator that one scientists called “the
king of beasts among the ciliated protozoa”
with an appetite that is quote “insatiable.”
The dileptus is not a subtle, lying in wait kind
of predator. It’s always moving, always seeking.
And when its proboscis makes
contact with the spirostomum,
it grabs a chunk of its body almost instantly.
The spirostomum is large and nimble,
and it pulls away quickly as if it’s been stung.
But it leaves behind a tasty morsel of itself,
which the DIleptus draws in until it’s
close enough to open wide and eat.
And from its safe distance away, the spirostomum
may not be whole again yet, but it is at least
out of reach of the dileptus, and of its
proboscis, and its hundreds of toxicysts.
You can actually see those toxicysts
here, when we look at the proboscis with
1000x magnification. And while the proboscis’
movement through the water may seem like a chaotic
mess of twisting left and right and up and down,
there is a surprising order to it all--driven by
the placement of those toxic cellular weapons.
The dileptus has to move in a way that lets it
immediately attack its prey upon contact, but
its proboscis is only lined with toxicysts
on one side--the side that leads to the oral
cavity. So it always sweeps its proboscis
with its toxicysts facing whatever is about to be
swept. And when it’s done moving in one direction,
the dileptus rotates its proboscis
and sweeps in the other direction.
Again, this is all so that when the dileptus
finally hits something, it won’t just make
contact: it will unload needles full of
toxins into whatever it has made contact with.
To learn a bit more about how these toxins work,
in one experiment, scientists filled a fluid with
the material coming from the Dileptus’ toxins.
They then placed some Paramecium into the fluid
to see how they would respond.
They did not respond well.
Immediately, the paramecium tried to mount their
own defenses by releasing their own harpooning
trichocysts. Now, that might have worked
against an actual dileptus, pitting ciliate
against ciliate as they poke each other for
survival. But in this experiment, with the toxins
permeating the fluid, the best the paramecium
could hope for was to delay the inevitable,
to use its trichocysts as a temporary fence
until eventually, it emerged to its own death.
Now, that is an extreme situation, one that
a paramecium would probably not actually find
itself in were it anywhere else but in a lab.
Fortunately for paramecium, we do not live in a
world full of Dileptus toxin fluid. Those toxins
are kept safely packaged within the organism
themselves, waiting for their designated time.
Which does lead us to a final question—one
that we do not have an answer for,
but that we like thinking about nonetheless.
We’ve seen the dileptus as a solitary organism,
and we’ve also seen it in groups with others of
its kind. But how? How does an organism that is so
simple, so reactive, so toxic—how is it able
to just casually entwine itself with others
of its own kind? How can they gather without
immediately all jabbing each other to death?
Well, we don’t know, but it means that there must
be more to the release of toxicysts than just the
simple mechanical stimulus of touch—that there
must be some sort of recognition that makes it
possible for two Dileptuses to know each
other. You might even call it chemistry.
Now, we don’t know the underlying signs and
signals that make that recognition possible.
But what drove this mutually assured safety
may have actually been something selfish.
Imagine for a moment that the palm of
your hand was covered in toxic needles,
and every time you touched your own body, your
palm tore off a piece of it. You would probably
not last long as an organism. You would need
some kind of way to tell your palm that the
thing it is touching is in fact the body
it belongs to and to not try and damage it.
The same may have been true for the ancestors
of Dileptus and of other organisms that have
toxicysts. They may have kept accidentally hurting
themselves over and over, often beyond repair
until evolution provided a new path, one where
they would be able to recognize themselves—and
perhaps eventually, even others of their own kind.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Wren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon footprint, and then offset it
by funding projects that plant trees and
provide clean-burning fuel and cookstoves
for refugees in Uganda. We will need a lot of
different approaches to stop the climate crisis,
and this is one way that you can learn more about
your carbon contribution and take some action.
You can answer a few questions about
your lifestyle so that you can see what
your carbon footprint is, and they’ll also
show you ways to start reducing it. Now,
no one can reduce their carbon footprint to zero,
but using Wren, you can offset what you have left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive
updates from the tree planting,
rainforest protection, and
other projects you support.
And we have partnered with Wren
to protect an extra 10 acres of
rainforest for the first 100 people who
sign up using the link in our description!
There are now a bunch of names that are coming
up on the screen. These are our Patreon patrons.
If you like what we do here at Journey to
the Microcosmos, these are some of the folks
that you can thank. And the good news is that you
can become one of them. All you have to do is go
to Patreon.com/journeytomicro
and become a Patreon patron.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.